you
[Music]
welcome on Polly today we are hosting
showing from Johns Hopkins University in
Baltimore Sri hyung and I met I think
for the first time 2016 when I was
visiting judge you but we properly
connected I'd say this year during the
MT marathon and he already taught me or
taught me and told me about his methods
for interpret interpretability in LP via
7c gradients and immediately after that
I was already able to use his ideas to
visualize the gradient flow and
information flow in my document level
machine translation systems so where the
stuff is looking at antecedents and
translations so that was very exciting
and today he's going to talk about this
original idea and I think also about new
research that I haven't heard about yet
so I'm looking forward to that that
one's alright and thanks for inviting me
and thanks for the introduction
so ok as promised I'm gonna tell you
something today about using interpretive
techniques invented income your vision
to improve interoperability for your own
team for 4 MP models the work presented
here are done in collaboration with my
adviser if you can and my colleague
hainan she so there any questions during
the talk I'll feel free to interact
media ask questions we have a 130 like
one hour in 30 minutes all right so this
talk will probably go on for 15 minutes
without questions so should leave any
time for questions alright so here's a
out live to talk I'm gonna start by
taking you through a quick tour of
interpret II get you up to speed about
what's happening in this field of
research especially in computer vision
and then I'm going to talk about two
pieces work that I've done in the space
the first one is about uncovering word
alignment from a near-empty system and
the second one is about benchmarking and
evaluating in interpretations using
lexical agreement annotations that exist
in LP literature and finally I'm gonna
briefly talk about some feature works
that wanna do
alright let's get started so um recently
whenever I go to a conference and I talk
to people they asked me oh what'd you do
recently I say oh I work on something
related in Tbilisi this is the face they
usually get so the big question people
tend to ask nowadays like a lot of
people care about if ability but we
don't really know what is inseparability
so if you look at the existing
literature in chopped ability
unfortunately there isn't a very
monolithic concept or like a very formal
definition about what is interval T but
today I'm gonna give you some idea about
what's going on in this research area by
giving you some idea about what people
actually mean when you're talking to
ability although it's not a monolithic
concept so the categorization of this
like this meaning is proposed in this
paper by Linton 2018 I think it's called
the methyls of inseparability if you
haven't read that paper I definitely
recommend you to do even if you just
remotely interest in this topic
so the two categorization I'm going to
talk about for the first one is about
building transparent models to do an
opiate House and the second one is about
doing this post hoc interpretation so to
illustrate the difference between these
two goals of interpret ility I'm gonna
introduce this toy example so suppose
you have a really fancy speaker that's
connected to all of your caches you have
a TV of CD laptop whatever and for some
reason the speaker's keeping giving you
this cracking and popping noise and
you're sure that speaker's fine so you
try to figure out which IMP is the
culprit and when you look at the we open
the cable box whatever that connects
your speaker it looks like something
like this so just live interaction what
would you do in this scenario any ideas
all right that's a good one
whoo - sorry to give you some options so
the apparent and tedious thing they
probably don't want to do is to rewire
the cables so what this is basically
doing is that you're building a
transparent model to do the same task so
in this case cuz you you have you have
sorting out all the cables it's pretty
easy to figure out which are they input
like giving giving you know like which
input the speaker is playing right so
this is talking about building
transparent models is that just set so
what this is doing is that it's you're
basically building another model they
achieves the same task but with like
easily explainable behavior in terms of
my give me this concept into like an LP
most people will probably agree that
most popular deep learning NLP models
are not the most explainable models so
what models are well it's actually open
question but just to give you some idea
one I think that linear model is a
interpretable model because if the
feature has a very high way then
probably that feature is important and
also some people would probably argue
that attention is somewhat interpretive
all in that eve attention if the
attention waits is looking at a source
word it's sort of mean that a source
where has a play a big role in that
transition this corresponding target
word we're gonna talk about this briefly
but looking 50 minutes more all right
but for most people we're just probably
too lazy for that we just want to keep
the model intact and just get the
student yet get some kind of
interpretation over the mode of behavior
so in that case what you want to do is
something called post hoc interpretation
so one thing you can do is that you can
ask a human
right you can listen to the speaker and
say oh this is this is a program see
from SIA and so it must come from a TV
the TV box so basically what this is
doing is that you're in your doing this
interpretation with a standalone model
but this model is doing different tasks
in in the sense that the original model
is taking the electric signal as the
input and transform that into the sound
where as a human when they are doing
this task what they're doing is that
they're taking the sound as the input
and give you a distribution over which
source is a culprit for this right so
it's a different model that's doing
different tasks so um another way you
can do something is that you can either
jiggle the cable to create some
perturbation in the source or as someone
just mentioned you can cut some of the
cables to just black out some of the
input so this is what this is basically
doing is that you're trying to come up
with some interpretation by evaluating
the sensitivity of the output with
regard to each individual features so
throughout this talk I'm gonna put a lot
of stress for this approach because this
is apparently what people use in
computer vision okay so to talk about
this approach I'm gonna do a little bit
abstraction of the toy example so
suppose this cable you have is can be
abstracted into this black bass model
and so what this is doing is that you
have a four-way classifier that takes
for individual implement outputs some
kind of class labels right and the
problem you're trying to solve is that
given an output you're trying to figure
out which input is contributing most to
this output okay and the cheek of the
cable project that I just talked about
now is that you're basically adding some
kind of perturbation to some feature in
the input and then correspondingly you
would get some perturbation on the
output all right so they
the problem is that if you like
intuitively if you apply a big
perturbation on the source your
corresponding might get a big
perturbation on the output right so what
you really want is some kind of relative
sensitivity they define something like
this and maybe you remember some
calculus when Delta X approaches 0 this
is really just a partial derivative of
the output with regards input there
you're trying to preserve so from now
we're gonna define this partial
derivative as saline C which is your
keep hearing this term like throughout
this time all right so what's good about
that but this sorry but good but what's
good about this alien C definition so
the first one is that remember like when
develop this saline C notion I haven't
made any kind of assumption about the
architecture of the model so you can
really just apply this to any deep
learning model that you're interested in
and the second thing is that if you if
you have ever used any kind of deep
learning toolkit you should know that
perspectives that really is it obtained
you basically do the forward pass and
you just call back or function right so
you don't really have to write a lot of
code or actually do the perturbation for
the forest step so it's pretty easy to
do so apparently because of this it's
really popular in vision so for this
example this is trying to interpret the
image classifier so the input in this
case is the image apparently and then on
the output you're try to output some
time the distribution of the class
labels about what is the most salient
object in this image and then for
interpretation part what you do is that
you take the you take some class label
and you get a corresponding score of
that class label right and then you
basically take gradient with regard to
each input feature of that that that
prediction score and basically here if
you look at the salience the map is
trying to tell you for each pixel what's
the what's the magnitude of the of the
salience in here so in this case
image seems like a monument or up Liske
but we look at the Stadion see it's not
all concentrating in the in that
monument thing because you see got some
kind of staining say feature on the sky
and cloud so there is some noise
associated it is kind of approach so
from this point unto the end of this
first section I'm gonna talk about to a
balanced way of computing this agency
they're still based on this notion of of
like using gradients you evaluate the
sensitivity of the feature but they have
their own way of like solving whatever
problem they come up with okay so the
first one I'm going to talk about is
this thing called smooth red so the
basic idea busman's grants that they
think well the gradients actually a very
local measure of sensitivity in the
sense that if you if you have a highly
nonlinear model like a lot of the deep
learning model that you build you may
have a lot of these pathological points
where the gradients are not really a
good representation of the of the
granularity of the sensitivity that you
care about and you may get all of them a
lot of noise with these gradients so
here's a toy example suppose you have
this output why did you care about and
by changing some feature value X the Y
would appear like a change like a curve
like this so basically most people will
probably agree that we increased X it
will positively contribute to the
activation level of Y but if you happen
to evaluate the gradients at this point
then what you get is a high is a large
negative gradient which in this in this
situation it means that X is negatively
correlated with with the predictive
score or Y so in investments you will
probably consider it as sort of a noise
so the solution proposed value this
smooth grant method is that you
calculate a D&C not for just the average
like a certain example input what you do
is that you construct multiple copies of
the same input but you compute you
construct these inputs by corrupting the
original example using our Gaussian
noise right and then what you do is that
having having gotten these different
versions of sitting see you average them
hoping that it cancel out the noise and
also you get a like a large scope learn
a slightly larger scope of the of the
sitting see of the future beyond the
like the very point at the example input
right so basically in this case what you
do is that instead of just evaluating
gradients X 0 you would evaluate using
multiple corrupt example like X 1 2 X 5
and we average you get something like
the blue line instead of the yellow
negative gradient so this roughly
correspond to what you think would be
the Stadion C of that feature okay so
that's for a smooth grad if you apply in
computer vision the same sample you
should see that there's less noise
happening on the sky on the cloud and
more sitting as if sort of concentrating
on the obelisk ok so there's another
method called integrated gradients this
involves a little bit of calculus so I'm
not going to go into the very details of
this method but I just aim to give you
some kind of high-level idea
so the problem they are trying to solve
is this problem a feature situation in
that if you optimize your network so
well such that we fit in the input
most of the feature will get 0 or like
very small gradients and they proposed
that they actually like from their
analysis they show that this is not the
best case to deploy this kind of
gradient based sensitivity map sensitive
they measure so what they do is that you
define a baseline which is basically
some input that carries no information
in the sense of computer vision you can
pass in like a Oh black image or a white
image either will be fine and I want you
to do is that you also construct
multiple versions of input but
you do is that you construct a
interpolation between the original input
that you care about and the baseline all
right so basically in this example the
original input is a stock and the
baseline is this black image and then
interpolation would be a like a darker
version of this original dark image okay
and then you basically also do some
averaging over different versions of
gradients and you actually average by a
kind of integration I'm not going to the
detail of that integration but this is a
high-level idea okay so if you apply
integrative gradients for that you get
reduced noise on the sky and but you
still get some noise on the cloud so I
mean seems like is doing something but
just pretend it's fine
for the moment all right so that rough
that roughly wrap up the first part of
this talk
so to summarize I talked about two
different goals for interpret II the
first thing is about building a
transparent model that gives you easily
explainable behavior and this is about
that that exclaim explainable behavior
does not depend on any kind of output of
the model whereas the second way I
talked about this post hoc
interpretation will keep the original
model intact but rather you will do some
interpretation that depends on the
amount of output and why do I talk about
all this kind of stuff how this related
to you the next stuff I talk about so
the first piece of work which is about
uncovering word alignment from UMT this
work is basically comparing a specific
kind of transparent model versus a post
hoc interpretation that we apply under a
specific user case that I guess a lot of
people here with care about which is
guarantee and the second thing is about
comparing different posts in a post hoc
interpretation method in a rigorous
quantitative way to get some idea of how
these the interpretation method actually
works for NP models so before I move on
to the next section any questions here
No okay
to move on so all right so I guess most
people probably familiar with this
material but let me just recap the
problem of word alignment is that you
are given a sin despair where the sent
entire article translation of each other
in this case is German to English and
you're trying to find some
correspondence between the source words
and the target word using the
relationship of like whether they are
work translations of each other so the
correspondence for this example will
look like something like this okay so
let's just apply this problem using the
interpretation veel that we just talked
about so you can view this as a model
transparency problem right and in this
case some people argue that Oh attention
in this case would be a transparent
model in that you can interpret the
behavior of the model using the Li the
attention weights so but there's just a
problem here so suppose we are in the
middle of translation where we translate
we the second way and we are about to
output the next word so in this case you
can give it a source input you can
either output only or should so a good
model in this at this stage should both
look at the word Noah in the source in
the source side which means only and the
word Zoltan which means shoot right but
the problem is that when you do word
alignment you actually have to all you
have the output so you're more than that
user word lemon should really depend on
the specific output choice that you have
already made so maybe model transparency
in this case is not the best way to do
this and we are going to show this like
empirically in the experiment section
all right so the next thing is about
doing post hoc interpretation using
standalone models which is basically I
want to build another model that model
that models the distribution of the
alignment pairs give him the source on
target
sentence right and apparently this is
something that people have done for a
long time like back in the era where Stu
when people still use the SMT system
they will use géza or a fast line to
come up with alignment for apparel
quarters okay
and what will you care about here is
that we want to do this pol second
interpretation with probation or like a
relative sensitivity measure so
basically in this case given this input
which is already mapped into a array of
work vectors what we do is that we want
to add some perturbation on the source
side and correspondingly you get some
perturbation on the target side which
may change the word should which may
change the art max self is arc max
output but still if you care about shoot
you should take gradients with regard to
the prediction score of show all right
so that's what reveals but now we have a
problem
I keep glossing over this term of
feature right and now it's probably a
good time to look at that in a more
detail way so if you think about the
notion of feature in computer vision is
pretty clear because if you zoom in the
image if you zoom in any image large
enough you will see individual pixels
and you can just very naturally use
these pixels as input features and when
you computer ad ins with with regard to
input features you can just compute
gradients with regard to pixels and get
some settings the map that we just
showed you which is straightforward
however everything that's about the same
problem in LP the input feature here is
awarded bedding right and you might say
well it's pretty straightforward to
compute saline see for each dimension of
embedding as well but everything about
it what we really want here for the word
alignment problem is that we want one
sitting z-score for one word right so
you have to do some kind of composition
over the same uses score of each
dimension of the word embedding to come
up with the synanceia of a word how
would you do that composition well
here's what
so this worked by Lee it out basically
did this form ISM where okay so for this
formula all the symbols are scalars okay
and why is the Perdition score of her
work has certain times that and E I is
just one dimension of the word embedding
so basically what it's doing is that
it's computing the absolute value of the
gradient of the word embedding and then
just average it okay and because of the
absolute value that's been done here the
range of this value is really from zero
to a positive infinity
just keep that man keep that in mind
we're probably gonna revisit that in a
minute okay we want to do something
different okay so here's our proposal if
you consider the word embedding lookup
operation as a dot product between the
embedding matrix and the one-half actor
alright and then if you think about what
that one-half vector really means if we
can really say that the one in that 1/2
vector denotes the identity of the input
word which is basically saying oh this
simple word is corresponds to this item
in the vocabulary okay and what we try
it what we want to do is that let's just
treat that one as a real value and let's
protect that one which is by saying that
I'm actually what I'm actually doing is
that I want to take radiance with regard
to that one in the 1/2 actor and if you
do some math derivation to figure out
what it actually means mathematically
you come with something like this so
this is basically doing a weighted
average over the over the gradients of
the word embedding and then the weight
of this weighted average is the original
embedding value and just to keep in mind
that in this case the range of this
savings to scores from negative infinity
to positive infinity which is different
from Lee's proposal all right why is
this different matter
so um recall that example where I showed
you that for
a certain for a certain time step you
can either output the word only and
should okay there are places during
translation that a input were may
actually strongly discourage certain
translations so in the example of only
and should these two words actually
contradicting each other because you can
only put one word over there so if you
choose to output where should the only
that the source were that corresponds to
only we actually carry a large negative
gradient because it's discouraging this
output right so if you ask me okay is
this word only a sinning word I would
say yes but in terms of where the lining
problem should they be aligned no
because should and only are not like
translation for of each other so really
what you really need is a polarity of
the Saleen see here for each of the
individual words and so basically if you
do something like absolute value or you
compute arrow to norm of the of the
Saleen see of each dimension of the
embedding you actually fall into this
pit where you get some value you get
some magnitude magnitude but you don't
get the you don't get the polarity okay
I mean you're gonna work in the
empirically show that this actually
matters in actual practice okay so
before we look at experiments I want to
talk a little bit about evaluation so in
general if you talk about if you ask
people Bell oh I want to evaluate this
interpretation people give you people
give you really weird looks cuz most
people would think that interpretation
is a pretty subject thing where like
maybe if you ask different people you
also give you a different interpretation
of a model output right but fortunately
for this case we actually in a better
situation because we're done I'm is
actually a problem that we care about
and people have built human judgments
for world alignments given certain
sentence pairs so we can rely on these
human judgments to evaluate the the
quality of our interpretation but
there's one more caveat which is saying
you only have human judgments for
certain
and certain reference right you cannot
get human judgments for any kind of
model output so what you need to do here
is that you have to do force decoding to
force them your MT system to generate
the the reference sentence that we have
human annotations off so this will have
a small risk in that sometimes you view
for some other to generate something
that's really unlikely you probably push
the model into some wild region where is
not trained to do but we actually did
some comparison using a free decoding
which is we just let the model to
generate or whatever it wants and
roughly saying it's it's pretty much
fine
so here for this presentation just gonna
present the results with force decoding
you're interested in the free decoding
results you should rate our paper
alright so let's look experiments so we
experiment with convolution of sequence
sequence model LCM and transformer
translation model and the data's that we
use is following Sankara 2019 which is a
which is the data set that covers German
English French English and Romania
English we actually take experiments for
both directions so when we apply smooth
weather to hyper parameter we have to
choose what is the number of samples you
take for the CNC evaluation why is the
Gaussian noise the variance of the
Gaussian noise you have to impose on
input so these are the choices we made
there so here are the baselines we
compare with naturally we want to
compare with attention weights but we
also want to make sure that this very
operation of smoothing does not improve
the performance by itself so we also did
smooth attention and now corrupt the
input in the same way as smooth grad and
then we average the attention ways
obtained using these corrupted input we
want to compare where lay it out you
know 16 and we also want to verify that
like smooth gravel like how does the
method like perform under the smooth
grant method
all right so here are the results so we
are we are presenting alignment error
right here and for this metric lowers
better okay so if you look at the
performance of attention looks like that
if you do smoothing it does don't do
better ish I do so sight it worse if you
look at the performance the pls method
is roughly the same as a tension but if
you look at our method without any
smooth wear a fancy stuff it'll read
that's met better than both attention
and Lee's method and if you use smooth
grant further you can get further even
better performance now here's a
interesting part if you compare our
method with facile ient which is a model
that is trained to do this kind of
interpretation we actually do slightly
better there this is actually notable
because fast line as I said faster is a
model that's trained to do word
alignment so all the parameter in that
model is optimized to do this
interpretation task whereas what we are
doing is that we are trying to interpret
a model that's trained to do translation
so it will learn some alignment
knowledge but it's not really optimized
to do that but yet by doing that
interpretation at least for
convolutional sequence the sequence
model we're we are able to do better
than fast night so that's not so cool
but honestly if you look a stronger
stand along interpretation models such
as adding extra module to do a lineman
on top of transformer or if you deploy
Giza plus plus which is a slower
stronger alignment model we're not doing
better than that right so that's one
group Group group of results so if you
look at the attention weights across
from different architectures you see
that basically convolutional the
attention output from the collusion
model perform best and the transformer
is pretty noisy there and if you compare
the results from our method across
different architecture
you get pretty significant decrease in
alignment error rate but still our
method is not strong enough to fully
bridge the gap between different
architectures and you still get the same
ranking interpreter architectures and
also only convolutional model that's
better than all of the standalone
interpretation models whereas if you use
if you use something that's noisy from
the start you are gonna get worse result
on top of that okay
so here's some examples to give you some
quantitative idea about what our method
is doing so basically the vertical axis
here is the source the horizontal axis
here is a target and because if it's
because it's alignment so each of the
each column is normalized to sum up to
one okay and you probably don't trust me
but all of these three great skill slots
actually drawn under the same scale so
basically you can see that our methods
are more picky interpretation of the
output whereas if you compare these
composition method with attention
they're doing pretty much the same thing
and I want to highlight one point here
so for this reference we are looking at
it didn't translate the source word
English the the German source word Noah
which means only so if you look at the
reference you don't see only there
however both attention methods and Lee's
method assign align some words to Noah
as certain time steps okay whereas our
method I mean is trying to align
something but Jenna is cleaner compared
to the app these two methods so this is
just say that our method is much more
robust to these kind of contracting
choices of words on a source site okay
so to summarize I talked about three
different kind of interpretation methods
to tackle this word alignment problem so
you can use
tension which gives you maximum
transparency about how the model
actually works but the only problem is
that is people cannot really understand
that because if you compare that to
human judgments of a word alignment it
does not really agree well in that you
observed a very high alignment error
rate and you can use that along
alignment models which give you the best
possible world alignment but has nothing
to do with the translation model so if
you want and if you do if you want to do
air analysis on the translation model
this is really not your choice
whereas our method is sort of a
combination of both words on the one on
one hand you get some exposure to the
model because when you evaluate
gradients you depend on the model to do
that and on the other hand you get
reasonably well word alignments so as
humans you can actually understand
what's going on there and probably
discover some patterns so before I move
on to the next piece of working a
question in your formulation that you've
changed from me to the problem the thing
I'm constantly striving with that is why
you are actually multiplying the
activations the embedding scores and
gradients right so you are doing the
circle sorry you are multiplying the
embeddings and D gradients so why does
that actually influence polarity because
isn't isn't the distribution of positive
and negative values in the embedding
smallest random right but if you have if
you have an active input yeah and you
have a okay input and you have a
negative gradients that's basically
saying want to increase the magnitude of
that level basically saying you want to
push it even more negative I can see how
the negative value goes to the gray it's
right because okay rules for an
automatic
ah differentiation tell you that the
multiplier gets passed through the
backward step but why doesn't matter
when you go forward as you perturbed us
through whatever weird activation
functions you have in there which might
not be homomorphic to multiplication
right I don't think I follow me yes so
yeah I'm not sure if I'm making any
sense at general all these signs are
basically arbitrary right when you can
flip the signs of the embeddings and
flip the other their corresponding
science in the first they are matrices
as would like but it's just that you
have the terrace where it's me because
doesn't actually mean anything so Chloe
doesn't that's why you canceled it out I
don't care
sign between the gradient under for
Americans as well as a consequence of
the solids the science arise off
okay
I still have understanded burgers like
Mathematica just a chamber oh yeah to be
honest yeah I see this in the backwards
I'm just wondering what's going on in
the forward step because I don't see the
meaningfulness of the sign when you go
forward try no actually like in the
forward step it doesn't make any
yeah it doesn't like connective and the
positive values doesn't make any
difference it's just arbitrary things
like rel which is cussing out anything
that's negative right and so on and song
has been learning to match the course
yeah why don't you call the other way
than the end result that's fine
no people assignment means anything in
an intermediate step but now the point
he's making is when you go completely in
to end it does mean something right if
you're starting from the word and all
the way to because because at the at the
output it does mean something I mean it
makes all the difference right I'm just
did you vary the bet don't understand
why that makes all the difference okay
thank you cause the final sentences last
day the sensitivity of the Inbox
yeah all right sometimes you actually
wanna know how jacket be sensitive see
is how how bearable that's
you mean like when you change it by
different magnitude yeah you kind of
average you averaged out together
something great you know hmm okay so um
in terms of that smooth great thing um
so there's a you probably aware that
there's a Gaussian like a Gaussian noise
that's applied to that and there's a
variance term right so when we we
actually turn that a little bit if you
look at the paper but we are actually
gonna be surprised that we actually end
up using the same printer as the author
like of the original paper and the
original paper was using was using a
like an image classifier to evaluate
their interpretation methods so I don't
know whether that's a coincidence or
there's just some sort of interaction
between human cognition and can they're
like the state agency of the neural
networks but yeah I think that's a good
point
but but here for us like the we didn't
really try to like like change a
different magnitude when we tune that
parameter we barely optimize for a bad
word alignment quality so that's what we
what the alignments work so differently
for conditional former all right so we
have something by the end of the next
section but yeah I I can answer that
question now I think it's mostly depth
so basically the transformer you build a
six layer transformer whereas I think
the I think the convolutional model of
the convolutional model and the LCR
model was like foliar 2 layer I don't
quite remember but like something
shallower so basically if you have a
longer computation chain there's just
more noise where it just spread out more
I don't have the like the alignment tab
for transformer here so this is for
convolution
model if you look at lsdm and
transformer transformer just everywhere
it's not as concentrated as here this is
a Motorhead transformer I think it's six
layer eight heads
it's everywhere for the attention that's
also right since Gretna
but it's less spread out for the
gradient that's right but if you pop up
a level - so the point you're trying to
make is that this war alignment is a
test case for interpretability right so
so what does that mean and when you say
that okay if I have a deep transform
where I don't get good water alignments
are you saying basically the transformer
is just not interpretive all no matter
what because it's too deep or this
method is the wrong method for trying to
interpret what transformers doing I
would say oops I would say it's mostly
the limitation of the interpretation
method we currently have does not work
for these deep models yet or like deep
and wait like Motorhead attention
whatever but the deputy's the quality of
like if you look at the nice clean and
doing math it doesn't seem to depend on
how complicated the box it makes up lies
exactly oh there's something wrong with
the with the intuition behind why this
this like you know there's like this a
very nicely intuitive sort of idea of
interpretability but basically you're
saying it doesn't work in the more
complicated cases because there's
nothing intrinsic to the method that
said that that tells you why it can't be
more noisy look better or worse
depending on the complexity of the model
right because the whole point of the
method is that all of the complexity of
the model has been squished into well I
don't really care I'm just taking the
day exactly that's a hope but still like
if you look at the salient like the
vanilla synanceia where you just take
the gradients um like if you look at any
settings and map that generally in
computer vision it's pretty noisy to be
honest look at the
like you had this smooth grad and then
the integrated cried like if you try to
be like we're very the hyper parameters
of that and like do like massively more
smoothing or more integration did that
did that make a difference if you do
massive smoothing like if you upon
applying noise with very high Gaussian
noise it's going to be in a very
everywhere yeah so it's not meaningful
at all basically you're just like like
intuitive figure just make your input
really vague such that it does not carry
any kind of meaning there so yeah I
would say there's a there's a
discrepancy between what we think this
method will work but what gave us with
what actually gave us and unfortunate I
would say like the description states do
like why is this this grimaces do occur
is the open problem and but on the other
hand I I don't think allowed the
existing interpretation research
actually a lake look at that problem
very rigorously so that's actually part
of the problem try to solve in the
research that I'm gonna talk about in
few minutes
any other questions
okay I'm gonna move on alright so the
second piece of work this is actually
ongoing work so I would appreciate if
you give me some feedback on this so
this is about building some benchmark
for interpretations using the existing
linguist annotations all right so when
we when we so the alignment example
alignment results where we were actually
pretty encouraged and say hey let's just
use this for other details that we care
about and let's be honest we are not
really the first one to apply these kind
of methods to an Opie tasks there's
working on text classification basically
roughly the same as in vision you the
tax classifier you want to figure out
which part of the tax contributes to the
prediction of this cost label something
going on okay there's the sentiment
analysis where you want to figure out
which source word are positive since it
carries positive sentiment which words
carries negative sentiment and there's
question-answering which is saying okay
which part of the document you can look
at to find out the like the answer for
the question okay
so all of these work give you some
insight about each individual task that
a caravel they sort of generalized some
pattern all the models doing this the
model is doing that and all those like
looking at certain things to make
decision so but but there's a underlying
assumption that's going on here
basically are assuming that by doing
this post hoc interpretation you know
this is how the model actually make the
decision right but this is actually is
this actually the case so that's a quick
flash back on the word align an example
so basically what you do here is that
given this target word prediction you're
trying to figure out which source work
is the most saving worse for predicting
this outfit right yeah you're trying to
figure out which source word is the most
important word for predicting this
output so if we just think about this a
little bit you have the source you have
the target you have to model how many
ways could a model make this the
decision well if you have different
model different model will make the
decisions differently right if you have
a different input or like you're
predicting different output word the
model will probably make this issue in a
different way but with all of these
factors constrained there's only just
one factual way that you can your model
can make the decision and yet when you
look at if you compare like different
interpretation method like the LEAs
method and our method you actually see
like very different interpretations out
of this interpretation method so what
I'm saying here is that these
interpretation this interpretation
method output are really just different
perspectives of one factual
interpretation that like it is purely
conceptual we probably cannot see it but
a natural question we want to sort of
ask is that how far is this are these
perspectives to this factual
interpretation and you should be you
should feel alarmed about
if these perspectives are actually far
from the factual interpretation and you
draw a conclusion from these Irenaeus
erroneous interpretations you may get
misleading conclusions at the end right
so the research question I'm really
trying to answer here is that how can
you quantitatively test the fatness its
effectiveness of these interpretation
methods in the context of NLP and moving
forward when you see different kind of a
level of effectiveness of this method
how like what kind of factors are these
effect name is correlated with like are
they correlated with model size the
performance of the end task and the
architecture so in computer vision again
this is actually easier problem because
let's take the image classify our
example again the reason I say it's
easier is because they would have ground
choose humanity ground truth for their
image for example this is a I think this
is the image classification for a
medical application what you get here is
that you're trying to ask the image
classifier to predict oh is this given
this x-ray image does this person have
and kind of disease and you can generate
some kind of interpretation by a human
basically saying oh this is there's a
tumor in this X array so this is a cause
of this disease and alternatively you
can use different kind of interpretation
method to generate a stadiums in map
with regard to this prediction and get a
like a get a distribution of the future
salience see on this map and then you
come compare these interpretations with
your human judgement to get an idea of
how well this kind of interpretation is
doing ok but for NLP tasks a major
problem we are faced with is that we
don't have ground truth interpretation
like that so what we hope what we hope
will do is that oh can we we actually
build a lot of linguist annotations for
a different kind of NLP tasks can we
leverage this existing annotations to
use them as some sort of this ground
truth interpretation so the case we look
at is the Selective agreement case we
study this case because this is actually
frequently studied previously for this
interpretive research but however we
look at this research they are actually
a little bit different from what we are
trying to solve here what they're trying
to do in these papers is that they
concentrate on evaluating this kind of
probing task performance namely given
the prefix or given a partial sentence
that captures are like the first part of
the lakhs of agreements can you predict
the the other part of the lexical
agreements properly so let me illustrate
this with the example of subject verb
agreements so basically you have
this prefix and full I can tell you that
following this perfect there's a verb
and the lemma of the verb is look
so given this perfect would you choose
to predict look or looks well let me
give you some hints for this
there are several nouns you probably
want to look at you probably want to
look at people you probably want to look
at footage you program on little cap
Bronx and decide which of this verb
should your should the number of your
verb be agree with ok and I guess for
most humans if you are like an adequate
in your speaker you should be able to
figure out that you should have kept
people which is the real subject here
corresponding to the verb and that to
agree with the number of morphological
number of people you should predict look
ok this is what I call as propping task
alright and that's what previous people
do now the problem I care about is a
little bit different so assuming we have
a model and the model think oh look is
more proper words in this situation in
that scenario which of these nouns
should the model be looking at or if you
do some kind of interpretation here
which of these nouns should the model
assign the most agency for that's one
case and the other case is that if the
model thinks oh looks is more possible
here does is the ground truth they're
going to change corresponding to that to
that different prediction so basically
following the situation the test is
constructed in this way so I'm going to
look at the saliency for the word people
and footage and Broncs here right by
interpreting this prediction suppose
it's look in the case of it's predicting
look which is the correct work I'm going
to ask the following question for this
interpretation does the interpreter does
this alien see a sign
for the subject people higher than any
of the other nouns which I would call as
attractors is the salience the assigned
for people higher than any of the
attractors because hi then we're going
to say oh this is a good interpretation
because it grieves me human intuitions
whereas if the model predict the wrong
verb I'm gonna say oh for one of the
attractors which has agreeing
morphological number as the verb there
the salience II for one of the attractor
should be higher than the saline C of
the real subject people which has a
different thing but doing the correct
thing for the correct reason exactly
that's nice yeah and I don't I I mean in
this case the reason I decide I just I
design different tests for different
prediction is that I want to separate
the interpretation from the prediction
of the model because I don't really care
about the prediction of the model I care
about under any kind of prediction kind
of interpretation method gave me a good
interpretation of this decision in its
good in the term that does they align
with human judgment because that's the
best ground truth we can get if you
don't agree that while human judgments
is the ground truth in this case then
it's a tricky this is some falsely
calling tasks I suppose and you know
checking if it's doing the right thing
in the right place so you can rank
models by this essentially weight
putting me well let's say it's two
different models okay they both predict
they both agree that looks is the right
thing okay but let's let's say one of
them it has higher wave of people than
the other one so okay the downside of
the one witness judging people to be a
better feature a better model are you
holding the interpretation method
constant well I meant low so it's really
the correct thing but it's also
or assigning more ways to the correct
reason for predicting the correct thing
so that would be a better model in an
evaluation setting I will be cautious
about saying that yeah it would be
better for such a firm agreed but who is
to say what it does for any other
particular phenomenon now let's say that
you have the last pestilence so my
question is because we are now getting
let's say for machine translation we are
getting two areas where are we having
we're having really good translations
everywhere so maybe the models aren't
making mistakes anymore but maybe you
still want to rank that so maybe you
should choose now among the models which
I'm not making any mistakes anymore the
one level which is not making any
mistakes for the right reasons but
because you kind of never thought of it
that way anymore ah right and - and to
make a comment about chore at home and
it is true that we only focus on one
kind of specific kind of phenomena here
but the but the situation we are faced
with is that you only get kind of you
only get annotation humanitarians for
certain kind of phenomena that's one
thing and the other thing is that you'll
only get a like a clear ground truth for
some of these phenomena and just to
reflect back on the previous previous
piece of work about were linemen the
reason we don't want to evaluate these
kind of interpretation on the were
dynamic data set which we also have
human judgments on is that if you
actually look at these human judgments
they're pretty noisy and I I personally
down some annotations for like people
who gave me some translations and say
okay can you can you align the Chinese
words with the English words and a lot
of times it's really hard because a lot
that's a lot of these translation or
like for example if you are translating
the some Chinese idioms into English
right like how's your line worse you
will want to like the phrase alignment
is pretty clear because you can line
this span with this man but saying
talking about individual words is really
not that easy
so you end up doing some arbitrary stuff
we're doing that annotation which causes
the human annotation for alignment three
noisy so that's why we don't want to use
that pass for evaluation whereas here
when we talk about subject verb
agreement always get a pretty clear
ground truth even the amount of people
with like relatively higher internation
agreement which is why we think this is
a good tactic that this kind of
phenomenon it's a pity that we cannot do
this for a lot of the other tasks but
again this is like a best effort of
trying to pin down what is the good
interpretation method as I said it's a
difficult problem because a lot of other
times there's a lot of subjectivity
associated with the kind of
interpretation so it's it's actually a
height of pre hard to evaluate yes model
of ranking I'm still thinking evaluation
then saying the model makes a mistake
that looks what you say it's better if
it makes the mistake looks and assigns
the highest-selling zoo to people well
that makes the mistake looks and assigns
the highest sales into footage gossage
if it looks of people it shouldn't have
made the mistake looks right right
everything looks as footage it might
have made it but it's still wrong for it
is things
so I don't think this work is trying to
make that judgment to be honest you can
come up with the liquor limited number
of his tricky question studying I
wouldn't make judgments on that okay so
in falseness there's no difference okay
I mean Cesar there are two independent
pieces of knowledge here and they argue
many different directions on that
because one piece of knowledge is
where's the controller and the other one
is given the controller what is the
right of community forum and so
obviously they aren't both intact and
one could be off on the other too often
it's not clear which is gonna be the
better yes day yep but anyway this is
not trying to actually solve solve that
problem like we're not trying to compare
the model we are trying to compare how
does interpretation method do with these
models
yeah so try move on any other okay so
under this no sure make a comment about
the difficulty are you were referring to
of doing alignment okay
um because it's really an ill-conceived
task to ask people to align words syntax
is not about words as you said it's
about phrases and so it's asking people
to do something that doesn't really make
sense and no no surprise that people
don't necessarily all do it the same way
and here it's not entirely different
either because you don't agree with a
word you do the phrase so you know like
if we have something to dear Bob while
we're seen or one deer was seen so
what's controlling the agreement between
was or were it's whether the phrase one
deer or
- deer is plural or singular and the
word deer has the same form so what's
the right answer for what words
controlling agreement there um it just
is the wrong question
that's a good point yeah so I think for
this specific test that I'm constructing
I am looking at the head of that race
but yeah you're right like for cases
like deer um
you cannot really tell a difference you
have to look at the whole phrase - so
great yeah there is discrepancy there
but um again like this is like a best
effort we can do to like it do some kind
of evaluation for these interpretations
okay right so under that framework we
construct a to test based on the
existing human annotated corpus one of
them's constructed using penn treebank
because we annotate the syntax a
syntactic structure of the sentence so
we can know which is the weight which is
a subject that correspond to certain
verbs and in that case for one verb you
might get multiple retractors in the
source sentence because there might just
be multiple nouns with different numbers
compared to the verb okay and the other
ones this what I call synthetic
evaluation was constructed by Marvin and
linson 2018 so this is basically
synthetic test that was initially
designed to make the language model fail
so there is constructed with a lot of
like confuse Leah confusing synthesis to
like try to try to identify the boundary
at the capability of the Lambs model to
conduct this subject verb agreement
tasks in this case because it's
synthetic
there's always just two verbs in the
sentence one subject one's the tractor
and so in that case this is a sort of a
cleaner easier case to evaluate and we
also want to we actually also want to do
another one
with not only like syntactic syntactic
relations but also some semantic
relations so we also want to look at
this correct resolution dataset where
like when you predict a pronoun I should
probably be looking at the corresponding
anti dimension that has the same gender
as this pronoun we are still working on
that
check me if intercept so okay let's look
at some experiments here so the model
that we're trying to interpret is as you
can probably guess it's a language model
but we did a little bit modification on
the original image model here in that we
replace the final linear layer with one
that's fine-tuned to predict the
specific agreement of interest here so
in this case it would be subject verb
agreement the reason we do this is that
if you just interpret interpret the word
prediction score let me introduce some
kind of out of scope agreement such that
the word choice may be associated with
some kind of inter or like semantic
relations or whatever which will
interfere with the evaluation okay so
the architecture of language model we
interpret here our LCM language model
train on wicked x2 curare model which is
a basically a convolutional language
model but is is designed to imitate the
behavior of the LCM national also Trina
and wicket x2 and we also did
experiments with transformer with
adaptive input this is a pre trained
model on wicked X 103 and interestingly
we try to train transporting language
model on weak text to we're not able to
do that and I actually asked around like
seems like Maryland community this is
something that's like no one is able to
do and no one knows the reason for that
I have some hypotheses if you're
interested we can talk later
so oh the fine-tuning that I just said
was done on wicked x2 and it's the
fine-tuning process is actually pretty
easy because if you doing subject verb
agreement you basically do some post
tagging to decide the morphological
number of the verb and then you just
find him
to predict the attack Hey right now
let's talk about the probing past
performance namely the performance of
the model to predict the morphological
number of verb like how many times well
it was a fraction of time it gets the
form of the morphological form of the
verb right so this is different from the
interpretation evaluation that I just
talked about so basically we did the two
data said this is pantry bang and that
is synthetic evaluation so as you can
see for penn treebank because it's
slightly more in domain and that is just
a newswire text we are Malo just do
better in terms of in terms of probing
tax performance and basically transmit
does the best in the other model assert
a excited worse on that and in terms of
synthetic evaluation because it's out of
domain synthetic as I said you actually
do pretty bad on that like you can see
like for else and cure and they're
actually lower than point five which is
basically worse than random okay so now
let's look at the interpretation quality
which is you do interpretation and
compare with the with the ground truth
that we construct it using the
humanization so basically the vertical
axis is still like the fraction of times
the interpretation passes the test and
we also do a pan and synthetic
evaluation I mean like the
interpretation method we experiment way
they're roughly the same as we did for
word alignment and just to explain this
random thing this is the case where
depending on the model prediction we use
a random value sinan see of the words
and evaluate that and for synthetic
evaluation it's pretty clear that it's
point five but for penn treebank slower
than point five because if you like if
you get the if you get a partition right
you have to assign more Cillian see on
the subject to pass the test so in that
sense it's actually a slightly more con
more
constraint case for evaluation so if you
do random you're actually gonna do worse
than point five which is what's
happening here so basically you can see
that again
Lee's method is sort of lagging behind
compared to our method and if you look
at different architecture if you look at
qrn and the give you the care
transformer you can generally see that
our method plus either smooth grat and
integrative gradients does the bastian
the other method but another interesting
trend is that when you switch from the
previous two smaller architecture to the
pre-trained transfer architecture you
observe a pretty steep decrease in terms
of interpretation quality here so um
what is happening here we had two
hypotheses one hypothesis is that if you
have deep model you'll probably hurt
integrability on the other hand there's
some study in in the empty literature
which is talking about oh if you have
too many has hovering around it will
hurt like it will probably do not much
about the transition quality and we
thought oh maybe these hats are hurting
instability so we have this set of the
our model which is the protein by
facebook they have like 16 layers and a
has what we do is that we try to reduce
the number of layers and the number of
heads so this is the same results I just
showed you now and this is a reduced
layer adept in hat model sorry this is a
reduced depth model that we trained so
we compare these model just by reducing
the number of layers you already get a
pretty steep boost in terms of
interpretation quality and when we
further reduce the number of has here
for some reason it's affecting the
performance of leaves method a lot
before our method is pretty stable and
to our surprise when we reduce to
who has liked the performance actually
got worse we actually have some other
results with different other different
kind of number of layers like eight
layers two layers and the consistent
trend is that the number of like
changing the number of has does not
really have a large impact on the
interpretation quality so seems like the
depth is a major Capri here um sorry why
you're not telling us so much how much
performance you're giving up by choosing
the smaller models right you give yeah
exactly you are not interpreting so your
arm you're aren't interested in those
small moves you're interested in the big
model look about that you can't show
what the big mother is doing so backing
off to a weaker more which what exactly
is this telling you not much at this
point right it's just that you don't
know how to interpret the big hole right
right that that's basically the
conclusion okay okay yeah if that's a
question that's answer that svenska I'm
not I'm not saying like these models are
again I'm not making judgments about the
model yeah I'm making judgments about
interpretation method it doesn't work
for large models yeah I'm not saying
like a smaller model is better because
it's more interpretive all that's not
all right okay all right so uh just some
quick qualitative checks before I wrap
up so we were wondering Oh like is our
this interpretation method just keeps
looking at the immediate previous words
and actually they're not so this is the
same example that I showed you
previously and you can see that in terms
of if you look at the smooth grad it
actually has signs no saliency are
people and in terms of integral for some
reason like however but still if you
compare these renounces to like peoples
do you get the most agency here and if
you look at the the interpretation we
get from different models intuitively
different models should make decision
differently and if you compare these
interpretation from different models
they are actually
pretty different from each other so in
some sense it's a good thing because we
know that we are getting some exposure
about the model with death does that
correlate with performance in your cases
so isn't it rather that interpretability
might be negatively correlated more than
performance than with them good question
that's experiment I'm draining right now
on the gray possibly possibly on what
you find oh okay depend on whatever I
know yes yeah so so the so the way I'm
testing this is that I'm gonna train the
same model with different amount of data
so if we reduce the number of date or
the amount of data you would do worse
right but you still have the same size
model size so in that sense this for us
to evaluate implants so maybe I'm just
looking at the same phenomenon from the
difference you're looking from the
bottom of it but we are looking from the
top and you're just seeing the same
things well I mean it's a good thing
yeah I'm sense right because it's
causing its own set of problems for us
both oh yeah but like for my perspective
I want to know like how about these
interpretations that works if that
verifies what you see from like
day-to-day production yeah it's a good
thing I mean their behavior sort of
predictable it's not like random stuff
right
okay so just wrap up this part of work
so basically we want to use axial
grievance to do rigorous Clinton checks
for post hoc interpretation and we see
that it does open up some possibilities
to do that and you can see again our
first proposed method with together with
smooth grad and great gradients works
the best complete consistently and as we
repeatedly made a point during the
discussion deep learning a deep LP
models are still sort of outrage for
existing interpretation methods so
there's some open research to be
addressed
there alright so just briefly covering
some of the future work that I kind of
want to do so one thing is that we
probably want to design some better
interpretation method for that work
actually works for deep architectures in
NLP and the second thing is that here we
are basically evaluating some
interpretation method how can we use
them in the real world applications for
example if we want to do some kind of
quality estimation for empty models if
you know better about the internal
decision mechanisms of these models does
it give you more insight to estimate the
quality of the output and also can we
use these interpret bility these
insights from interpretability to
improve our models and lastly there's
there's a ongoing interest about like
using different kind of interpretation
method to propose to to probe certain
linguistic properties in these kind of
large pre-trained language model and I
think probably if you use if you borrow
some of these interpreting method from
computer vision you can probably do
something with like these line of
research so
[Music]
so we are doing this with different
types of data and you are trying to make
your deep models worse right right
instead make your shallow models better
teacher-student training
oh okay trying the student which has
slower death and the teacher what is
nearly matching it to the performance
it's also a map in emulating the
teachers probability distribution and
everything means that thing is easier to
interpret then you have a case right
because I always am always very when you
make things worse and then try to say
something about it I think it's better
to make things better and trans to say
something about that but if you can
interpret the teacher what is that say
no you copy the block if you can tell
you if you can interpret and interpret
the student you know and it's the
student this modeling very similar
probability distributions of the teacher
then it's not quality bound and you can
at least say that it's death but not
performance because I'm the question is
that's that's the interval in the
credibility correlates of good
performance but does it correlate with
architecture if the stone has the same
performance what easier architecture is
easier at the protocol then you have I
think removed the performance angle you
could do the third one which is to train
a student with the same architecture of
the teacher not a reduced architecture
yes I mean the same realm of experiments
that would be very because the thing the
the data the students learning from has
been regularized in a very interesting
way and maybe that it
anyway that's my last time thank you
let's guess for example I find it days
like a model does a bad thing is there a
way for me to trace that back to the
tweeny didn't say that okay these 10
examples between data the ones that made
the model that's a short answer but
because the image specifications it
seems to be some research that way give
an example see you were given like a
result specification you can kind of
look at which images new training data
activate like that class was you can
kind of like that in that because do you
have to retrain the model using the like
the examples that you care about is that
something that's happening now this is
Sally but you cannot trace it back to
like which images made the model like a
tip that way okay don't say that you
can't do that you just need to have
examples where it went wrong
yeah or maybe I think the problem might
be that you also wouldn't need to have
ground truth where it's right but the
model doesn't like it for some reasons
yeah so I guess that's hot in others
it's easier because we saw this those
medical images where it was very clearly
highlighting the an art are something
that's easy but for language I would
have a hard time to construct similar
minimal casts one example for example
like to be mexican-american
come on Winkler you weights sometimes
the models that generates like a token
that's got no white got that zombies
talking about scars and they generate
houses so you can like maybe trace back
that token in a training it I'll learn
some kinds of pathways okay I have a
hard time like trying to reform the way
of hard works but um you only get your
gradients on the source right or on
history
you don't get it you don't get the
target part that left him on the
straight so let's see how the training
parent correct sauce incorrect packages
so the incorrect target isn't
manifesting in your arrow tracing method
anywhere when you do this mr. so you do
not know what pattern to look for you
only find a pattern go to look for the
source that we might find that but you
are not seeing the incorrect target that
makes your model learn the incorrect
thing I guess that never gets in the way
unless it's somewhere in its history so
you have a previous decision then you
can make it can trace it back even there
it's hot but I really see plenty of
examples where I generated shows
yeah yeah on the other hand I'm aware of
some research that tries to analyze if
there's any kind of data leaking that's
happening for Mt models for example if
you are if your model is generates this
output then by some possibility it's
looking at this data set which might be
like confidential or whatever it's more
on the line of like a privacy research
but I so first thing I don't think that
relates how much that relates you the
question there you were talking about
and secondly I don't think they use
anything that's related to inter ability
here I mean in the in the privacy I mean
has anyone tried to measure how much of
the training corpuses can be just
replicated like in a few great
translator training courses how you know
how accurately right I just know that's
roughly what that paper
[Applause]